Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. So, the first week of interviews for the clinical doctorate have happened which means that from this week onwards we might well be expecting we are expecting the first people to get their notifications about whether they're being offered places whether they're being offered reserve places or whether they are being told thank you but not yet and you know a whole array of feelings can be experienced as a result of that most definitely if it is a no, thank you, not yet, then some of those feelings you're experiencing might be complicated, painful and jagged. And yeah, as humans, it's not only ourselves that can find it unsettling when dealing with those painful, complicated feelings, but also those around us as well, either because it makes them feel uncomfortable or
because it just stresses them to see you experience them and we can feel disappointment about all sorts of things like big and small you know on a very small scale I feel a bit disappointed that I worked quite hard on my hair this morning it was beautifully curly and then our lovely spring weather in the UK means that I've been caught in a rainstorm caught in squally winds and it's just you know it's not how I planned for this to go it's not how I imagined it all to work out and that is a very small scale problem you know it's a nicer problem to have isn't it but on a larger scale disappointment can feel really really difficult you know um and sometimes people will say to us especially for job stuff especially if you've had an interview for something or if you've even been turned down for an interview for something sometimes Sometimes people will say, well, you can't really be upset
because you never had it. You know, it was never yours. To that I say, bunkum. To that I say, codswallop. To that I say, well, utter rubbish. Because with our fantastically tricky human brains, we begin to imagine the things that we're going for coming to fruition. We begin to plan the moves. We begin to plan, you know, how that's going to feel, how exciting it's going to be, you know, and you're only applying for these things because you really want them, you know, or sometimes you apply for things you don't really want. And then you get offered it and you're like, oh, that's made me realize I didn't want that. Just kind of did it speculatively. But often, and most of the time when we apply for things, it's because we really want it. And I think the thing with psychology is, is that you're often seeing people who are celebrating the thing that you might be commiserating.
You know, for your average job interview, you're not having to actually find out ever who got the role. Whereas if it's a specific course that you've applied for and you've been told, no, thank you, not yet, then you might well on LinkedIn or Instagram or Twitter, see someone celebrating their win about getting on that course. And that would have potentially been your future cohort mate, you know. And it's really difficult because then our comparisonitis creeps in as well. And I just want to send you some love, really. And you might even feel disappointment if you get offered one place but not one of your
favorite places and then you're thinking well this is going to be a bit tricky in terms of making this work for my family for my personal circumstances but I feel like I need to say yes to this because I'm so lucky or you know so many other people want this but actually you did want course A more than you wanted course B and then likely your life will follow the path of course B but not always if you recognize that that's not for you you can still say no you know it might feel like a cardinal sin to say no to a funded doctoral place, but you still get to choose, you know, you still get to have a life that feels vibrant and full and worth living and like a bit of you, you know. It's very difficult, it's very difficult. So yeah, just wanted to let you know my heart is
going out to you right now, whatever you're feeling're feeling and of course if you have got a doctorate place and it is for a course that feels like a bit of you and going to fit into your life either because you're going to move your life to it or because you're already within appropriate safe traveling distances of it or you're just going to make it fit you know you're going to do some airbnb um you know three nights a week and you're thrilled then i'm so thrilled for you as well it's okay to celebrate as well even though others may not have been in the same fortuitous position as you you're allowed to be super super proud so yeah if someone is saying well you can't be upset because you never had it, then you can say, well, I can be upset because I am upset because I'm a human. So are you going to sit with me as I'm upset? Are you going to, you know, or are you going to go away and I'll be upset by myself?
You've got choices because I'm feeling upset. You don't need to chiv me along. You don't need to distract me. You don't really need to cheer me up this is disappointment and I will move through it but right now I'm sitting with it because I'm a human and that's what we do so I'm really hoping that all of you get the news that you want but obviously more of the personal stories for people that I've been involved with during this application season are people in my aspiring psychologist membership I just want to take a moment to read you a little review about a session that someone attended recently. So this says, so the question was, did this session better prepare you for your journey as an aspiring psychologist? And the answer
was definitely. I find the membership so helpful and it gives me more confidence that I can speak and formulate an answer on the spot. So if that feels like something that you have struggled with in the past, really, you know, getting everything you need to do to fully enrich your answers, to be able to get the depth of answers that you might well need for psychology interviews, then do please consider coming on board to the Aspiring Psychologist Members pounds a month but there's no minimum term so you can leave if you decide it's not for you and if research is a tricky area for you then don't worry we've got that covered too so when asked about our research about our research, whether it had been useful. Somebody had said, it was literally everything I could ask for when prepping for the research aspects of the interview. What is not to like? So yeah, if you feel like that would be useful, those two examples would be useful for you then come on board the water is lovely
but I do still of course I'm passionate about offering free support for you whatever stage you're at in your journey so these podcasts will remain and of course we've got the compassionate Q&A that you can come along to live so we had Monday the 13th of March, and that was the one that never actually happened. It did in fact happen on Tuesday the 13th of March, and you can catch that on my YouTube channel. If you're watching on YouTube, please do subscribe. If you're not watching on YouTube,
take a moment to just scroll to YouTube as you listen and subscribe to Dr. Marianne Trent. You can watch the replay there, but you can also come along for the live sessions via my socials, Dr. Marianne Trent. The next one is on Monday, the 17th of April, 2023 at 7.30pm. Replay will be available if you can't make it. And the next one after that will be Tuesday, the 2 of May 2023 at 7 30 p.m too please do bear in mind that the clinical psychologist collective book and the aspiring psychologist collective books can be really useful prep for you in terms of thinking about how you are reflective and how you might appropriately share that at interviews so do bear that in mind listen to a quick jingle for one of them now and I'll be back along very shortly I'm the way to get to qualify. So many tips and lessons to learn from.
So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective Are you still loving those jingles? I hope so. They're often in my head and I'm singing them. And I even found myself singing the one about Dr. Marianne Trent the other day, which felt slightly narcissistic. So I would love it if you would come and connect with me
on my socials Dr Marianne Trent everywhere pretty much and keep keep me up to date with how you're doing right now let me know where you're at if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes that might be useful for the stage of your career that you're at right now then do please get in contact and let me know because I want to make sure that this is really useful for you whatever stage of your journey you're at. Do always remember that there's the free supervision shaping tool that you can access from my website as well,
www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision. Thank you so much for watching and listening and being part of my world i will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode which is available from 6 a.m on monday take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.